since we brought up
uh drugs let me ask you
this is becoming more and more part of
my life because i'm talking a few
researchers that are working on
psychedelics
i've eaten shrooms a couple times and it
was
fascinating to me that like the mind can
go
like it's fascinating the mine can go to
places i didn't imagine it could go and
it was
very friendly and positive and exciting
and
everything was kind of hilarious in in
the in the place wherever my mind went
that's where i went
is uh what do you think about
psychedelics do you think they have
where do you think the mind goes have
you done psychedelics
where do you think the mind goes uh is
there something useful to learn about
the places it goes
once you come back you know i find it
interesting
that this idea that psychedelics have
something to teach
is almost unique to psychedelics right
people don't argue this about
amphetamines and
that's true and i'm not really sure why
yeah i think
all of the drugs have lessons to teach i
think there's things to learn from
opiates i think there's things to learn
from amphetamines i think there's things
to learn from psychedelics things to
learn from marijuana
um but also at the same time
recognize that i don't think you're
learning things about the world i think
you're learning things about yourself
yes um and you know what's the
even it might have even been uh
might have been a timothy leary quote i
don't want to miss phone but the idea is
basically like
you know everybody should look behind
the door but then once you've seen
behind the door you don't need to keep
going back
um so i mean and that's my thoughts on
on all real drug use too
except maybe for caffeine it's a it's a
little experience
that uh it's good to have but oh yeah no
i mean
yeah i guess yeah psychedelics are
definitely um
so you're a fan of new experiences i
suppose yes because they all
contain a little especially the first
few times it contains some lessons that
can be picked up
yeah and i'll i'll revisit psychedelics
maybe once a year
um usually small smaller doses
maybe they turn up the learning rate of
your brain i've heard that
i like that yeah that's cool big
learning rates have pros and cons
you